je voudrais dire tout d'abord évidemment
toutes mes pensées à ces deux policiers
gravement blessé à leur famille et à
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre qui se
dévouent sans compter et qui garde
malgré tout fois dans leur métier leur
mission alors évidemment ce qui s'est
passé est extrêmement grave
je rappelle que aujourd'hui l'uniforme
exposé il est censé nous protéger et en
même temps ils exposent ceux qui le
portent ces terribles et ça montre bien
à la fois la perte d'autorité de l'état
et puis une violence que rien ne semble
pouvoir contrôler à l'égard de nos
valeureux policiers et gendarmes de tous
ceux qui sont là pour pour nous protéger
et je pense que cela a été dit
d'ailleurs par l'orateur précédent je
pense que aujourd'hui les policiers se
sentent trop seul se sentent trop seul
ils ne se sentent pas suffisamment
protégé par les pouvoirs publics une
chaîne pénale qui ne fonctionne pas
suffisamment des peines qui ne sont pas
suffisamment exécuté donc il ya une
situation des faits qui est très grave
et je ne crois pas que ce soit les
discours martiaux qui puisse répondre à
la gravité de cette situation qui menace
véritablement non seulement l'ordre
public mais je dirais la république
elle-même constaté c'est facile agir
c'est plus compliqué les choses
les républicains ont fait des
propositions extrêmement précises sur
lesquelles la majorité et le
gouvernement n'a jamais voulu s'exprimer
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale par
exemple pourquoi ne pas s'emparer de
cette question quand on voit l'âge de
plus en plus jeune des auteurs de faits
de violences de plus en plus graves
la restauration de la double peine
la construction de places de prison
emmanuel macron avaient promis la
construction de nombreuses places de
prison il n'a pas tenu sa promesse et on
est à une grosse année l'élection
présidentielle donc il y à il y a
véritablement là une responsabilité du
gouvernement qui est engagée et
il lui appartient il lui appartient de
mettre tout en oeuvre pour restaurer le
respect de ceux qui portent l'uniforme
vers lesquels aujourd'hui toutes nos
pensées se tournent